um it makes me think about one of the
first questions you ask about whether
the transgender community are
bullyingists and i think one thing that
one argument that's been used against
the lgbtq plus community as a whole is
that they often force their beliefs upon
other people yeah so if you are someone
who does not agree with their beliefs um
the same way religious people might not
agree with each other's beliefs
how do you
disagree
in a way that isn't offensive or
disrespectful i think what it is that's
a good question i think it comes to this
notion hurt people hurt other people
so what happens is they're in a they're
in the state of fight or flux so any
sort of disagreement
they think it's an attack on their
identity i'm just trying to be
charitable i'm not saying i agree with
this notion i'm just trying to be
charitable for them so if they're grew
up in a very very
conservative home whereby everything's
okay they were called every single slur
under the sun the f word and stuff like
that the other f word and all of a
sudden now someone who's socially
conservative even though it's tolerant
to say you know what i know you're gay
we can still be friends but i disagree
with this because of xyz they're always
going to see it as i said because their
brain is flight or flight mode
that's me trying to be charitable
towards them i'll say i agree with it
that notion you know i'd say i'd say the
lbgtq community
if you use their own logic
they can't exist and when i say that i
mean this the l in lbgtq means what
lesbian right okay and a lesbian is what
a woman is like let's check it women
right but they're women but i can be a
woman
don't even get me started right so if i
can be a woman
that means i can be a lesbian can i
really be a lesbian yeah
what does the g mean
gay what's gay two men but the ma but
men can now be women
so what's gay but it's not supposed to
it's not supposed to be socially
coherent
so using their own logic
the lbgtq community doesn't even make
any damn sense yeah but it's not
supposed to be socially cohesion it's
not supposed to make you feel good not
necessarily so
be logically consistent so it's
validation yeah one issue i have with
the acronym is that what does the lgb
have to do with the t
the same and i can uh give you a
parallel sounds like that sounds like
dave chappelle but go on no but no it's
true though but because i'll give you a
parallel
when it comes to um culture and race
what does b-a-m-e what does a black man
have in common with an asian person and
why are you boxed into the same box i
agree acronym there because
realistically i've got no idea what it's
like to be black i never will even if i
get stupid in this debate and say that
just i could never understand what it's
like to be a black person ever i think
what it is to answer your question it's
a good question it's a bit like similar
what happened in the second world war
did the
did the alliance and russia have
anything in common
not really they had a common enemy in
fighting obviously hitler yes hitler was
defeated
it's like yeah
that's what's happening with the lgbt
community they have a forced alliance to
say we have a common enemy and that's
the conservative so who is the enemy
though because when you think about it
the conservative white
but the thing is though conservative
white men voted for gay marriage
so when you're boxing the lgbt
what does the tft
they have to create a boogeyman to rally
people because like i mentioned before
most people are mostly emotional than
rational
i know but when you think about you
using the word conservative and you look
at historical examples more
conservatives fought to end
slavery they thought they fought in the
civil war they were they were pro-ending
slavery in america you've got
conservatives voting for gay marriage in
england like i don't really understand
why conservative minded individuals i
mean conservatives did i mean if you
talk about slavery you're talking about
william wilberforce who was a
conservative but he he was abnormally
against the conservative party at that
time because he was one amongst many
what i'm saying is i'm giving like a big
big example of how conservative mindsets
have actually improved things and i
don't understand why minority groups and
i don't like that phrase by the way use
that as a scapegoat of saying which
conservative white men i don't really
see that i actually think white people
have got a lot more compassion than what
we're given credit for actually when it
comes to what some groups like to
portray us as
it's i i see your point i think like i
said it's narrative narrative sales not
necessarily coherent logical arguments
so it's narrative that sells and if you
tell a good story people believe it more
than they believe call what happens when
you talk about white people i think it's
the uh the the reason the reason why is
the unfor the unfortunate
history of white people is racism
right
colonialism
slavery
all that kind of stuff yeah
it's it's the history of white people
right and so
it's a hit it's a history of white
nations
so what happens is like um any was
saying before what's what's more
impactful the earthquake or the actual
aftershock right so people so people
will us will associate
whiteness
with
slavery oppression oppression
colonization
all this kind of stuff i don't believe
all white people are racist i really
don't but does racism exist yes it does
do racist people exist yes they do
um and so the whole thing is is that
when it happens for instance i've spoken
on like the whole blm movement that kind
of i know we're going off but we'll go
back on um i've spoken on the whole blm
movement et cetera et cetera and i've
never
never as a black person i've never
supported blm
right so
because i i saw the i saw the actual i
saw it for what it was i was like this
is like a scam you know what i mean i
mean only candice owens now is coming
out and saying that it's actually a scam
do you know what i mean because she's
done the research but i'm saying the
reason why is because the unfortunate
history of of of white people is that
you have a history of that
and it's and i'm not saying it's your
fault but i'm saying it is what it is do
you think that answers your earlier
question about why you have
um black people being more liberal in
the western countries because there is a
historical hangover that is prevalent in
american and british society from
history
100 i think i think black people i think
all peoples
are a product of their history
oh i have a question do you think should
define you though no because i don't
because but the thing is what happens is
that people get into ruts
people just get into
oh my mom did this so i'm going to do it
or my grandma did this so i'm going to
do it that's why if the reason why
people vote people of black people in
america have voted democrat consistently
for the past 50 years why because their
grandmother yeah
and i listen to a podcast it's called
generational trauma
so that's probably why we explain some
of the
thinking behind why black people vote
democrat because
you know even though if you look at on
paper it was the republican it was the
anti-slavery party
but obviously and it was the democrats
that obviously formed the kkk and stuff
but because what the media tell us i
think oh
they swit yeah
about majority demographics as well
because because white people
have or did industrialize
slavery but white people didn't start
slavery no arabs did yeah
yeah and i know that i don't know that
because i researched it
after watching one of mr garvey's videos
and i was like educating folks out yeah
that's it and i went and looked it up
and i was like this is kind of like
blowing my mind a little bit that
actually it started off
in tribes yeah selling
black people around and then arabs
coming in and then just
you know and again it backs you up again
about people being
very devilish and very fundamentally
yeah yeah there's a human nature yeah
that's it
so when we're talking about histories
and we're talking about whether they
define us or not um for people
like so let's say for example for white
people um
but they feel really passionate about um
black people and their rights and their
issues and things like that or someone
who isn't transgender but they really
feel um so passionate about their issues
and things that they go through do you
think people who are not a part of that
community
are or haven't faced those struggles
themselves can fully advocate
um or
yes like once
change continue that i'm gonna go to the
bathroom
i feel like yeah
i thought it would be stupid of me to
say you're not black you've never
experienced it so you can't really be an
advocate
the more allies you have the better
hence the lgbtq because the l the g and
the b's
don't necessarily identify or understand
right the the trends and whatever else
but yeah the common allies you have
you know the more you can push your
movement forward and i think it's a
great question you've asked but i think
it also highlights how divisive society
is right now yeah that you need to ask
that question
because you know like i said a moment
ago i don't know what it's like to be
gay black whatever
but i wouldn't want anyone to hurt you
yeah and i wouldn't want anyone to take
away your rights as a human being
exactly but i can't relate to whatever
you've been through because you're black
or because you are gay yeah but i would
still want you to be okay you know what
i mean i don't understand but i stand
with you yeah yeah exactly and i think
like
you've mentioned a few times now it must
be the word of the show majority
demographics you're not you ain't going
to change anything in england without
white people yeah
yeah you know or straight people because
i'm sure there's more straight white
people than there are anything else
and i think it's the language you use
like for example i was mentioning before
before the show we have a tendency to
talk at people instead of talking to
people there is a difference talking at
people saying you're racist you're a
white privileged male you know you must
apologize for what your ancestors do
you're not going to get anyone anywhere
with that attitude if you spoke to me
that way i'm going to say f off yeah but
he said if you talk to someone and say
this is what we mean by it you know and
define it because i think sometimes we
get lost in the
the terminology i don't like the word
white privilege because i just think
it's such a yeah yeah i think majority
privilege is probably a better way so
the person you're trying to speak to
doesn't feel attacked can listen and
maybe
process it and understand
connection sorry
um how do we deal with ignorant people
because um ignorance yeah
i'm joking folks i'm just joking i'm
joking please don't don't do that they
can often be very harmful to society
yeah it's easy to say okay yeah cool if
someone doesn't agree just let them be
but a lot of the times people's opinions
can actually end up being really harmful
to society so how do we if they get into
power right so how do we deal with
people who are ignorant do we just i
think i i think education yeah it's
education but the thing is um even going
along this this subject matter i think
this conversation is educational right
right and so if we were to have and we
have had people who have opposing views
right
i think when it comes to the left side
of
the agenda
they are less willing to have the
conversation
and i've seen when it comes to the
transgender um argument i have seen the
left just shout try to shout people down
just try to disrespect people don't even
let people have a conversation you're a
transphobe you're an ex-wife like you're
this you're that you're this you and
it's like
how do we have a conversation about this
without the shouting because i think
people who
who want to understand
and maybe who don't understand
want to have a conversation about it
i've noticed that the people who are
so i've said the left have become the
fascists of nowaday
like they've been because fascism is
like shouting people down you can only
do this totalitarianism
you you shut down all forms of education
on it
it is what it is and i've found that the
left
is doing that more so the conservatives
because people thought that was a
conservative thing to do but i've found
that the left is doing that more so than
than the conservatives though so yeah
education had how do you
have what did we do with ignorant people
and if educated
yeah
um
relationships with people i don't know
if you've heard of daryl davis
that guy who formed him
no he's the one that he's a black guy
but he was the one that was speaking to
the kkk
and stuff like that and i think
sometimes forming a relationship
can bring powerful can be powerful than
just giving logical arguments because
people don't care what you know unless
they know that you care